11th success of increase Kimberly and
what I suppose the interesting thing
okay a lot of people thought they were
going to raise interest rates by another
quarter percentage point so in a sense
not not a total surprise there although
it's partly because of the fact that
inflation was so high earlier this week
that everyone thought that was really
likely the only interesting kind of
unexpected thing is that they have
looked at their forecasts and last time
they did their forecast which was not
long ago back in early February they
thought the UK was going to face a
technical recession what's a technical
recession it's when you have two
successive quarters so three month
periods where you're Contracting where
the economy is shrinking they thought
last time around that we were going to
have a technical recession in the UK
this year this time they say they no
longer believe that so they've upgraded
their forecast in particular for the
second quarter of the year so that's the
one kind of coming up into the summer
and they think that whereas they
previously thought the UK was going to
shrink by I think 0.4 now they think
actually we're going to increase a bit
so that's quite a big upgrade and it
implies that the UK is narrowly likely
to have avoid a technical recession so
people will look at that and say this is
actually quite good news and quite
unexpected good news coming from the
bank it's not their formal forecast they
only do that every three months but it
is a sign that they are basically
heading towards a better outlook for the
economy than many people have thought
and partly explains why they still think
extra tightening of monetary policy
raising interest rates in other words is
necessary they think they're still a bit
a bit more oomph in the economy than
previously expected and why does this
come back to it comes back to the fact
that not long ago people thought Energy
prices well I thought the people thought
they were it's that futures for Energy
prices looking in a wholesale Market
what was broadly priced in was a really
big increase in Energy prices and any
process to save really high for much of
this year that's gone away now so the
market doesn't look quite so bad for
Energy prices those wholesale prices
they're wholesale I should say so we're
not seeing them yet but they should feed
through into lower energy bills than
they would have otherwise been I'm
afraid it still doesn't necessarily mean
this year's not going to be tough but it
means it's not going to be as tough
you're not going to have as big a hit to
people's real household disposable
income so the pound in your pocket
feeling as was previously expected so
put all of that together and the bank is
slightly more sanguine now about the
state of the economy than it sounded
only a month ago but set against that
the fact that we have had all this
financial turmoil recently you've had
banks in the U.S collapsing you've had
what happened to Credit Suisse uh
basically a near collapse of credit
Suite one of the world's biggest banks
as well put all of that together and
there's an issue here which is that as
the bank you know Bank of England here
but also other kind of Bank central
banks around the world as they raise
interest rates that's causing extra
pressure on the financial system which
in turn is contributing to all of this
instability so there is a bit of
nervousness here it's not quite so bad
in the UK as elsewhere because we
haven't had so many of those problems
this time around famous last words but
there was a bit of kind of tension
between the plans to raise interest
rates to clamp down on inflation and on
the other hand the fact that the
financial system is looking a lot more
vulnerable now than was only a kind of
month or two ago that being said the
bank has raised interest rates 7-2
decision as you were discussing a little
bit earlier which is actually a little
bit clearer cut than expected and that
upgrade to the forecast definitely will
cause a lot of people to wonder oh maybe
things this year aren't exactly
brilliant but certainly we're a little
bit less Grim than they looked only a
month ago
so Ed what does that mean for the next
rate decision do you think it will be a
pause well
I we're gonna have to say I mean so at
the moment the markets are expecting
another rate hike because later this
year whether it's the next decision or
the one after you know we'll have to see
usually they do tend to hike when
they're having a big kind of look at
their forecasts again
um
but I think we're gonna have to wait and
see because that's more finely balanced
than than previous decisions by at the
point this morning when the decision was
announced kind of between 90 and 100 was
the probability that people had assigned
it to in the markets and the the
probabilities now are kind of slightly
lower on the next ones but all of that
being said we're going to have to wait
and see markets expect another hike so
up to four and a half percent some
people even think it could be higher
than that but there's so much going on
at the moment you'd be a mug to guess it
given that you've got those financial
tensions that I mentioned a moment ago
so problems with the banks you've got
the fact that the economy is potentially
more inflationary than people had
thought recently so 10.4 CPI in February
that was a bit of a surprise actually a
big surprise so if that continues well
that is the Bank of England's job to try
to keep inflation down so there's going
to be some concerns there and all on the
flip side you know there's it is a kind
of period of great chaos at the moment
when people are kind of trying to work
out what's happening to inflation the
economy and the financial system
so it's you know no one quite knows for
sure but right now yes markets guess at
least another increase in interest rates
up to four and a half percent
um but we'll have to say
okay Ed but what do you think that means
for our banking system and actually for
the global banking system because if you
keep raising the rate don't you then
expose fragility in the banking system
which is what we've seen with the
Silicon Valley Bank UBS and Credit
Suisse
that that's exactly the tension and
essentially what's happened is when
interest rates go up and you know we've
come to kind of forget this slightly
because it's been such a long period
since interest rates have gone up but
every time pretty much you've had a big
increase in interest rates around the
world that has led to problems in some
banks because it just changes the the
nature of your balance sheet the
valuations you've got people who are
invested in certain things like
commercial property for instance which
don't tend to do as well when you've got
higher interest rates and that goes
across the piece so there will be a lot
of people who'll be getting quite
nervous right now because even as the
bank raises interest rates that is
contributing potentially and it's not
just this bank it's other central banks
around the world Swiss natural Bank
National Bank raising interest rates
this morning also obviously the Federal
Reserve last night by another
quarterback point but what that kind of
contributes to when money is getting
more expensive is a financial system
that is sometimes more brittle than it
would otherwise be and that brittleness
is what's showing now no one knows for
sure you know whether now we've seen all
of those problems you know we saw it in
Silicon Valley Bank that bank that
collapsed in the US we saw it in Credit
Suisse at the moment we saw it you could
say last Autumn with the pensions crisis
in the UK the the ldi pensions crisis
that followed the mini budget to some
extent that was because interest rates
went up so fast and the expectations for
interest rates went up so much no one
knows for sure whether there are extra
time bombs buried out there but what
people do know is that when interest
rates are high it makes the likelihood
of things exploding a little bit higher
so I think that's why this year is going
to be quite a nervous one because the
higher interest rates are the more the
nerves in financial markets and let's
not forget it's the job of central banks
like this one not just to try and keep
inflation under control but to keep
Financial stability under control as
well so they've got two jobs and to some
extent they're kind of butting each
other right now because inflation looks
like an issue they need to raise
interest rates for that but interest
rates are a problem Financial stability
and they raise Financial instability so
we'll have to say difficult balancing
acts we're going to hear from the bank
of England Governor Andrew Bailey a
little bit uh later on clearly about
that initial decision I'm sure he'll
have a lot to say about that but he
might well talk as well about what
happened with Silicon Valley Bank of
course they had a U.S subsidiary which
also got kind of there was a force sale
partly initiated by the bank of England
managed by the bank of England to HSBC
so we might hear a little bit about
those kind of financial tensions and
what they mean for The Wider economy